there's this sort of prevailing
unilaterally accepted myth that if you
play
any species of shooter and want to
develop some truly sick aim
you must absolutely
turn off
mouse acceleration almost every
experienced aimer will tell you the same
thing go into your clients window
settings any third-party drivers you
might be running and make sure you
uncheck any sort of box that might
inadvertently accelerate your aim it's
like rule number one of the high i'd
like to fps please starter pack the
reason for this of course
is rather intuitive by accelerating the
speed at which your cursor moves by
accelerating the speed at which your
mouse moves you make the math behind
your aiming mechanics exceedingly more
complicated and tamper with the
intricacies of your muscle memory in a
way that's
just
stupid right does mouse acceleration
screw up your aim or
does it have the ability to level it up
to forge this sort of high sense low
sense hybrid whose mastery as a handful
of utterly cracked competitors have
already demonstrated might actually
offer the best of both worlds
let's find out
[Applause]
do the things
thanks all right so first things first
what is mouse acceleration and i swear
this one isn't just for the league
players out there like in theory
the concept of mouse excel is actually
pretty straightforward it's just that in
application it can be
really complicated so let's start with
the theory side of things to reiterate
mouse acceleration is a feature that
accelerates the speed at which your
mouse cursor travels depending on the
speed at which you make your physical
mouse movements this means that with
mouse excel off if you move your mouse
slowly from say here to here the cursor
will traverse whatever distance your dpi
permits at the same exact speed with
mouse excel on traversing the same
distance at the same velocity won't
actually make any difference it's when
you flick the mouse quickly that said
acceleration actuates causing the cursor
to fling further than if you'd had
acceleration off how much further you
ask well that's the part where the
practical complication of all of this
comes into play you see in order to use
mouse acceleration
or at the very least understand it you
need to make pitiful use of this big
scary thing called math
more specifically
something called an acceleration curve
now for those of you that never took
calculus
this might be a little daunting for us
kings and queens who did it's really
very basic the curve charts either the
exponential or incremental growth of the
sensitivity multiplier as determined by
the exponent you've selected to be the
wait why the [ __ ] am i explaining all of
this i literally have someone on deck
who they pay to do that colton do me a
favor buddy and just dumb this down for
all the
psychology majors out there and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about
you heard him
we're not even gonna stop at calculus
either
that's right
physics
okay i'm mostly kidding i just needed an
excuse to show off my fancy textbooks on
camera because
what else am i supposed to do with them
just to make sure we're all on the same
page acceleration is simply defined as
the rate of change or delta for my
fellow science nerds in velocity per
unit of time and this change can occur
in many different ways you can have
variable or constant acceleration and
generally third-party mouse drivers will
display this with a combination of
graphs variable acceleration especially
when we're talking about mouse
acceleration tends to take the form of a
logarithmic or exponential curve either
gaining speed quickly then tapering off
essentially hitting a maximum
sensitivity or ramping up slower but
then gaining speed well
exponentially or some combination of
these two graphs if you want to get
really spicy i guess we can see these
curves in everything from the default
csgo and logitech acceleration curves
all the way to microsoft's enhanced
pointer precision that is horrendous
please promise me that you won't play
games with that abomination turned on
regardless there is an alternative to
variable acceleration that i and plenty
of others way more qualified to talk
about aiming would recommend a constant
acceleration graph will give you a
linear acceleration so there's a steady
and much more repeatable connection
between the speed you move your mouse
and the change in sensitivity the only
variables you have to worry about are
setting the maximum and minimum
sensitivity and how quickly you want to
transition between them aka the slope as
i'm sure you've already guessed muscle
memory is going to come up a lot in this
video and in terms of building up
consistent and repeatable motions a
linear acceleration graph is either your
best bet or at least the best place to
start if you're planning on doing a dive
into mouse acceleration the raw excel
guide has a very helpful breakdown of
each of the parameters to help you tweak
each setting to your liking and
hopefully find something that works well
for you see that wasn't so bad i didn't
even break out any of my calculating the
slope at any given point in the curve
calculus
you're welcome and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
so yeah that's how mouse acceleration
works the question of course is
what's the point of it like does it do
anything for you
well for starters it makes your mouse
movements more efficient which is super
fantastic if your goal is to become
super cracked at like microsoft office
the world champion of excel 2016 an
exceptionally hard category kevin
matthews
how do you have competing spreadsheets
how does that work
they give you a packet of instructions
and a bunch of data and you use those to
recreate a file and i believe that
you're also an accomplished pianist and
mathematician is that correct
yes
that's correct
that ladies and gentlemen is [ __ ]
esports somebody signed this kid like
faze kevin dimaculangan when memes aside
mousexl seems great for things like
productivity and esports involving tons
of fast top level apm intensive macro
clicking like mobas and
rts's the question
is whether it's any good for shooters
and let me tell you
for a long time
it was you see back in the day when
arena shooters were all the rage desks
and mouse pads were smaller and a lot of
mice pcs and pc games had mouse
acceleration on by default a ton of
world-class aimers earned their keep by
mastering the intricacies of set
acceleration here to help expose it that
esteemed epoch of esports history is
none other than one of its constituents
competitor turned coach turned reputed
fps instructor ron rambo kim my first
experience with mousexcel was in quake
3.
so
back then i was still playing
counter-strike professionally but i
loved quake it's just a fantastic game
and you know i was watching the pro
players and i wanted to copy them and so
i downloaded one of their configs
and without me knowing it it had mouse
excel in there so
i had totally got used to it without
even knowing it and like really it was
it was such it was a point one
it's such a mini school amount like i
couldn't really tell the difference when
i went between counter-strike and quake
when i turned it off like i could
definitely feel it switching off from on
um in like the kind of close range duels
and fights to this day if you jam out in
a frantic fast-paced fps where shit's
constantly flying around you like quake
diabolical even overwatch it actually
makes a ton of sense for you to at least
give mousexcel a whirl but as the
popularity of arena shooters started to
wane and the father-of-tack shooters
counter-strike started to really cement
itself as esports's premier fps so too
did this fast flitty unreliably
modulated aim start to become regarded
as this
cursed uncultured thing of the past
we've got two sensitivity with default
windows sent so six and uh no mouse and
so on default windows sense six i also
play with raw input
for now keeping this off is considered
generally wise within the gaming
community one of the reasons for this of
course is that in a slow methodical
shooter like counter-strike where low
sensitivities run rampant you want every
movement every pixel you traverse to be
stupidly precise in games like
counter-strike where it's more tactical
and slower paced and the action happens
in front of you and you kind of just
know where to place your crosshair you
know where the fights are going to
happen you don't need that drastic
movement left to right anything left the
stylish one out of perfecto nico
he's going to be pushed to ot or can he
claw something
two to go that's not to say that there
are not some truly exacting executioners
out there who crack a shitload of skulls
on high sense but even they operate
within the bounds of raw unhindered
one-to-one aim since as we've all been
told over and over again it engenders
such excellent muscle memory at least
that's the prevailing wisdom
but as with all accepted norms
there are exceptions you see over the
years there have actually been a handful
of big names in counter-strike who've
managed to crack the upper echelon of
competition whilst accelerating their
aim i got rn put off
mouse excel on
and the acceleration amount is 1.05
that's default
i play with mousexcel because
brax uses it but it's safe to say that
the most revered of said radicals
is the peak pioneering head popper that
is
zantarez i'm ready for a flash whenever
you call i think he's jumping
nothing has changed mannix entirely
still has to feel good with an
acceleration multiplier of 1.05
and some of the filthiest raw mechanical
talent of any aimer alive xantara's
stands apart as a mythical unicorn who's
seemingly spliced together high and low
sensitivity into this like super sense
of sorts for me if i move my wrist it
has this amount of mobility
so i can only move my mouse this
distance without mouse excel but if i
figured out if i could do a 180 by doing
like a half wrist flick of my half wrist
bend and i was just you know and i
figured that out and i built that into
my memory um i would have an advantage
over the person that has to do like a
full wristband and a half wristband
so you can kind of maybe incrementally
break down depending on the degree of
your wrist bend how much mouse excel
affects or helps you
and then you can increase or lower that
value which begs the question
could mouse acceleration help foster a
deeper more dynamic style of aiming
think about it with excel on you could
maintain a slow and steady dpi when
making micro adjustments but the second
you need to spin around and 180 a fool
execute a high velocity flick that
quickly turns you into a high sense
robot i mean [ __ ] man just watch
zantara's do it mousexl definitely has
his advantages right like you can move
your mouse or your crosshair more
distance with less space depending on
the situation keto finally put to rest
after all of the damage at the beginning
of the rounds and terrorism season 2 vs
3 now that centaurus turns out to be an
absolute beast what even was that that's
an instant 180. how does he get that
okay so like we need to check him pc and
game right because that is
that is not normally they don't actually
have a kit picked up i don't know if
there's one on the bomb side but yeah
they need to do something here he's
getting tagged a little bit they know
where he is but it doesn't matter he's
gonna get four kills and now he sees
video there's the ace at the end what a
absolutely beastly round from centaurus
don't be
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
but here's the thing right
if mouse acceleration allows aimers to
reap the benefits of both types of
sensitivity high and low then
why doesn't everybody use it right
well as you can imagine
it's because it's not that simple for
starters it can be a nightmare to not
only find a good accelerator but to fine
tune it to your liking across multiple
esports titles especially those where
certain third-party accelerators have
triggered certain games as anti-cheats
some mice even though you use the same
sensitivity it's going to feel different
it's going to move a different amount
and then when you have mouse excel into
that it's just like i gotta find this
completely new
mouse acceleration value to match my new
mouse sensitivity value so you know
you're you're stacking on
additional variables like that if you
change mouse pad has different surface
friction speed so
it's just a multiplier variable that
makes it very difficult to
to not only learn but also get
accustomed to new equipment but
more importantly
the movements themselves
are trickier to master if i were to try
to learn mousexl and maybe i was testing
these different softwares
it's even difficult to do that because
it's like if you move your mouse at five
miles per hour and six miles per hour
how do i know i'm moving at five or six
every time and then if i move it that
six it's going to move it the crosstalk
a little bit faster so it's it's hard to
kind of capture that metric
and it's totally based on feel so
some days you know your forearm position
or your posture is different and that
affects you know your angles or your
forearm and how you kind of maneuver
your arm and stuff and then the next day
you wake up it's different and then that
affects mouth sick sound again it's just
like this
you're opening up a whole whole you know
a whole other set of variables that you
are relying on your feel to know if
you're being consistent with raw
unadulterated one-to-one aiming may in a
sense be viewed as limiting but it's
also approachable intuitive and reliable
people just sit in corners
might come 90.
oh you're insane here to help explain
why is none other than cracked mainstay
dr madison karkowski a professor of
computer human interaction at the
university of saskatchewan turning mouse
acceleration off did kind of emerge as a
strategy for beginners for learning um a
new fps for learning a game like
counter-strike because well mouse
acceleration speed is obviously
dependent on the distance that you move
your mouse which introduces a kind of
moving variable or a floating variable
as opposed to no mouse acceleration
which is more on the surface level
consistent or at least it requires less
mental map mental calculation adaptation
to those kind of
variations in movement so i would argue
that then because you remove that extra
variable of needing to be cognizant of
the distance you move your mouse and how
that influences mouse acceleration it
actually represents a reduced cognitive
load for those who are learning a new
input modality in a sense then turning
off mouse excel is sort of akin to
playing on stretched or turning down
your graphic settings all the way
insofar as it simplifies things for your
brain gives you less to think about
and by extension allows you to focus on
the things that do matter and when you
have that reduced cognitive load when
you don't have to think about your mouse
inputs as thoroughly you can instead
start to focus on other critical um
parts of learning the first person
shooter for example weapon spray or
learning the map learning call-outs
oh my god
and it's because of this that for years
the tendency of experienced aimers has
been to instruct newer ones to simply
turn off mouse excel from the get-go so
by simplifying those import mechanisms
by turning mouse acceleration off it
reduces you know that extra thing that
you need to think about merging of
action and awareness of becoming one
with your mouse i suppose a little bit
quicker because you don't need to worry
about we don't have that added cognitive
load with that extra
variable that extra factor that you're
needing to learn or that you're needing
to account for it's also because of this
that said experienced aimers
rarely if ever introduce it into their
own skill sets since they're terrified
of creating even the slightest
disturbance when it comes to their
well-honed muscle memory you know
sensitivity is
you know the holy grail of a fps gamer
it's like finding that perfect sense
you've got
total mouse control you know sensitivity
control crossover control that's what
you want
so
if you start adding mouse excel it you
might go into this black hole where it's
like
um
you know i was better on point two
mousexl but you know if i was on point
three i would have hit that shot and
then you're starting to mess with that
on top of your sensitivity so again it's
just
um
you know it's one of those very advanced
values and feelings that
i would only recommend for the expert
players no idea you came from quake have
you ever played with excel i did play
excel waltz in
source but because all the
counter-strike players basically were
like why are you doing this you know it
just kind of got taken out of me
pretty early on obviously as people
became um better at playing the game um
they became frozen they're not gonna
revert to mouse um excel on because
they're now used to mousexl off right
and um they're not gonna mess with a
good thing at that point but you can't
help but wonder
should they like if mouse excels this
super fancy advanced mechanic that's not
beginner friendly enough for novices but
way too weird and out there and
different for well-established experts
then
who's it for like shouldn't these
experienced aimers who are looking to
level up their game at least be giving
it a shot that's the question that
youtuber pingify set out to answer about
midway through 2020 and if you haven't
checked out his video on the subject you
should it's excellent after he an
experienced fps player immersed himself
in mousexcel for an extended period of
time
he walked away something of a fan am i
going to keep using mouse excel
yeah i think i will i still love the
crazy reactions i get when i say i use
it but more importantly it feels good to
use i can finally use that stupid low
sensitivity i really enjoy without
giving up the crazy wide angle aimbot
moments and i believe that i still
haven't spent enough time to master it
yet and he's not the only aimer to be
pleasantly surprised at how much they
like it or maybe i should turn on excel
right now just a little bit this is
going to be fun i'm really high
interesting
nice
content
the default
oh
now does that mean that everyone and
their mother should up and adopt mousexl
and that we should be indoctrinating new
aimers with it from the get-go
not necessarily
hell some newer titles like valrant
still don't natively support us but
should we as esports enthusiasts at
least be a little more open-minded when
it comes to potential benefits
probably i think it would be very neat
to do a study on this where you have you
know one group of novice players who
have never played counter-strike before
you introduce you to the game you get
them to um have mouse acceleration uh
turned off and then you have the another
group with nels excel left on and uh you
know return to them in a month and see
how they perform return to them in six
months and see how they perform because
that would be a much needed way of sort
of approaching an answer of you know
mousexl versus no mousexl like does it
take time longer to learn we might see
something where you know we might see um
the the group that has mouse
acceleration turned on it might take
them a lot longer to um
reach a certain standard maybe the mouse
xl off group would reach that standard
faster but they might eventually
overtake the mouse excel off group
imagine how nutty some of us would be if
we'd picked up mousexl from the day that
we first took up fps
and while picking up the feature today
isn't gonna like turn you into xantares
or anything at a moment's notice
you'd be surprised at how quickly even a
veteran aimer could adjust to the change
you know old dogs can learn new tricks
right i totally feasible for you to
learn it obviously there's going to be
that frustrating um week or two week
window where you're not performing
anywhere near what your standard is
because you're adapting to this new um
interaction with your mouse and that can
be kind of a major uh turn off in using
mouse acceleration because you know it's
very easy to get frustrated and just be
like screw it i'm going back um so i
would say if you're interested in uh
adapting to mouse acceleration you do
have to give it you know a good college
try like give it a good two weeks to
adapt to it um and see how it feels for
you so do yourself a favor and start
accelerating your [ __ ] just for the hell
of it just to see what all the anguish
is about there are no guarantees that
it'll turn you into a more capable
complete and dynamic aimer but
you won't know unless you try
so try
let's go making fun of psychology major
let's go
it's it's the [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
the get you know the the arms crossed
the oh like yeah
yeah
make colton dimitri making fun of psych
majors
yeah i think that [ __ ] all the time just
cool yeah that's bad that's right
physics
oh these textbooks are heavy
god i'm a nerd
no one's gonna be confused you know what
it's a youtube guys it's youtube like
the video do the sub it's your boy here
turn on notifications